I've been reviewing beauty products
for more than 10 years so not a lot
of things excite me but these things did
this year and I'm going to tell you why
and because I am a chemist and a massive nerd
I'm going into the science behind why as well
maybe some of these will also become your
favorites but if not hopefully you will
still learn something new that you can use
when you're finding products for yourself
if you tried any of these let me
know what you thought in the comments
let's get into it
the olay super serum is the best new
product I've tried in a really long
time I did a sponsored Instagram
post on this but this video isn't
sponsored I'm purely talking about it
because it was such a standout product
so for all of my sponsored posts
and review posts my process is
I'll look at the claims and ingredients
and if that all makes sense then I'll try
it on my skin for usually 2 weeks maybe
more depending on what the product is
this is really important because even if
you know everything about cosmetics you
cannot tell just from an ingredients
list how well most products work
it's got limited information the overall formula
is really important so you really
need to test it on actual skin
so for a serum that has actives like this I will
start with my skin at its best I'll be
using my standard skincare routine for
a few weeks then I'll start using the
new serum as the only active product
I'll still be using things like cleansers and
moisturizers and sunscreens that I'm really
familiar with so I know what they're going
to do to my skin I can see any difference
then usually over the next few days
there'll be little skin issues popping up
my most common one is closed comedones these are
little flesh coloured bumps that
pop up usually around my jaw area
they're when a pore gets clogged it's
sort of like a pimple but not quite it
could very well veer into pimple territory
but it's just buildup happening in a pore
I'll usually let that go on for
a few days then I'll know right
this serum just doesn't work
for that so I'll blitz them
usually the products for that for me are
alpha hydroxy acids and a peeling gel
then I'll just keep using the serum see if that
happens again go through this process for a bunch
of other skin issues and then by the end of
the trial period I'll have a really good idea
of what the product is and isn't good for which
products and ingredients it's good at replacing
sometimes my skin will just hate a product or it
might not do much and then I'll go back to the
brand and tell them sorry I can't do a sponsored
post on this I can't endorse this product
and most of the time even with products that I
really like and recommend there will be little
issues popping up and that's fine because most
serums aren't really designed to do everything
but with this serum this is one of the very
few products where I went from my skin in
peak condition dropped all my usual hard-hitting
actives and my skin just sort of stayed the same
so basically this just replaced all the
actives in my normal super optimized
maintenance routine without making
any sort of noticeable difference
I think I ended up using this continuously for
like 5 weeks because I just was so surprised I
was just waiting for something to happen
and nothing did I was just using this
then I had to add a retinoid back in because
this doesn't have a retinoid and I want those
long-term effects that I talked about
in my retinoid video and that threw my
skin out of whack and I had to add a whole
bunch of other stuff in to deal with that
it was sort of like one of those
old lady swallowed a fly and then
eventually she ate a horse kind of situations
but if my skin wasn't such a baby
when it came to retinoids I feel
like I could have used this as the only product
in terms of what's in it it's got a whole
bunch of actives and I was pretty skeptical
at first because usually when you have a
product with tons of actives there will
be one active that they'll really focus
on getting to work really well and then
the other ones will just be sort of
sprinkled in for marketing purposes
but this does seem to get several
things to go on at the same time
the main Innovation here is olay managed to
get niacinamide to stay active at a low pH
and that normally doesn't work very well
but they worked out a way it is patented
Olay and Procter and Gamble did
a lot of that original research
on niacinamide for skin they're kind
of like the niacinamide science people
so this makes the niacinamide get into skin a
lot more easily and according to their testing
data this works a lot faster than olay's
other best best niacinamide products and
since niacinamide does a little bit of everything
in skincare I think that's why this works so well
plus it has lactic acid as its
second active and lactic acid
is one of those things that works
really well for my clogged pores
on top of that there's also palmitoyl
pentapeptide 4 which is one of the better
supported peptides there's one of my favorite
vitamin C derivatives there's also hyaluronic
acid and panthenol so it is really gentle
and non-irritating and it's also hydrating
I didn't actually need to use moisturizer most
of the time when I tried it and
that was in winter in Australia
the main downside of this is that it does have
a moderate level of fragrance which is actually
quite a nice fragrance to me but I can imagine
that some people might be really bothered by it
the other big downside which is possibly a
bigger downside is that it hasn't launched
in Australia I don't know when or if
it'll launch maybe it'll launch with
slightly less fragrance because Australian
products do tend to be lighter in fragrance
so when I went to the US and smelled your
products I find understood why everyone hates
fragrance so much because it was just like
the average level was just really obnoxious
olay also have that really annoying mass
market brand thing where they have a whole
bunch of products with similar names there's
a whole range called super serums but as far
as I know this formula only comes in
this like pretty shiny round bottle
this isn't really a new innovation but it made
a really big difference to my life this year
working out how to find eyeliner
pencils that stay on oily skin
my eyelids are super oily so eyeliners
always just smudge or start transferring
after a few hours and I didn't really
know what exactly I was looking for
I'd look for reviews where people
say particular eyeliners were smudge
proof but then they would smudge on my lids so
clearly my eyelids are just a whole level above
so here's what you're looking for
number one you want a volatile
solvent at the top of the ingredient
list volatile means that ingredient
evaporates really easily and these are
the most common ones you'll see in makeup
the solvent itself isn't the bit that
makes it longwear but it's it's a sign
that there are film forming polymers in
the product that will stick together after
those solvents have evaporated off so the
solvent basically leaves and then the film
forming polymers they can get together
and form a really nice long-lasting film
the second thing you're looking for is snug
packaging and again this just shows that
there are volatile solvents in there there's
enough in there that they're looking for gas
tight packaging so that stops these
volatile solvents from escaping and
evaporating and making your product dry
out and shrivel and turn into like a lump
if you remember the gel eyeliners that came in
pots they were super popular maybe 5 10 years ago
they're a lot less popular now because the
same tech has now been put into pencil form
it makes it a lot more practical as a product
because then you don't have a separate brush
that you need to carry around and it doesn't
dry out and you have to wash the brush and a
big part of why they're now in these pencils
is because of these packaging innovations
some brands have been using these for
years but there are way more coming now
basically for a really good gastight seal you
need one hard component that mashes
into a soft component with pressure
that's the same principle behind how screw top
products work they just kind of give you a way
of mashing like the hard top of the container
into the soft seal on the inside of the bottle
so for eyeliners what you're looking
for is a really thick lid that feels
like it really jams on you can
kind of hear them creaking on
this is my favorite gel eyeliner pencil it's
from Revlon and I hate Revlon because they
always make these really good eye products
and then just randomly discontinue them
all the time and I'm really annoyed but I
keep going back because they are so good
this is a pencil in a barrel that you
need to sharpen and that is generally
easier to make gas tight but these days there
are wind up products that work really well too
this is the Maybelline Master Liner
and this one is cool because the
wind up part is actually inside
the lid so you can see like the
the crack where the two components
join is in there inside the seal
also see that this packaging just
overall has very few lines and gaps
on it and you can see there is this
kind of thick seal inside the lid
the Merzy first gel eyeliner is also one
of my favorites this is a wind up product
and the winding part is on the outside
but it's got a surprisingly good seal
it's also got like the thick lid that
jams on as well you can feel that the
winder part is quite stiff and so yeah
there is a good seal in there and this
hasn't dried out I've had it for quite
a while now but yeah super good product
another thing to look out for if there are oily
ingredients that are high up in the ingredients
list that is going to be riskier and one of the
common ingredients you'll see there is dimethicone
it's not a complete deal breaker there
are products that work really well with
dimethicone high on the ingredients list
and dimethicone does make the product apply
smoother but it does increase the chances
that it'll smudge if you have oily lids
basically it acts like a solvent
it acts like a makeup remover along
with your own natural oils and that
dissolves the film and makes it smudge
and speaking of solvents dissolving
next we have the Bioderma eye makeup
remover so I have raved about the
bioderma micellar water so many times
it is hands down my favorite no rinse cleanser
micellar waters has surfactants in it
these are the cleansing ingredients that
you'll find in every cleansing product like
shampoo body wash even dishwashing detergent
but there are a huge range of surfactants
available it's like a really really big
diverse family and so the innovation
with these micellar waters was to find
surfactants that clean well but they aren't
irritating if you leave them on your skin
now some micellar waters don't
do this well which is why a lot
of people who have tried maybe one or
two say you absolutely need to rinse
micellar waters but this one was actually
designed for and tested on sensitive skin
so this is really really gentle
works really well for most people
I found this so useful for evenings
when I couldn't handle washing my
face at a sink and dealing with all the water
it's also been really useful for washing my
face when I'm trying to avoid a particular
area like a few weeks ago I microbladed
my brows and I had to kind of like paint
around my brows so yeah this year
I went through another few bottles
but the new product I wanted to talk about
is the biphasic micellar eye makeup remover
I've always really liked two-phase eye makeup
removers this is where you have like a layer of
oily stuff over a layer of water I found that
these just work really well for removing eye
makeup they're really gentle they don't need a
lot of tugging and yeah it's just quick and easy
but one of my big annoyances with these
is that the two layers usually separate
way too quickly so you shake
it and then you have to race
to get it onto your cleansing
pad before it starts separating
if you get too much oil on it then it
ends up being really greasy and leaving
like a greasy layer on your skin if you
get too much of the water layer then it
doesn't take off eye makeup as well and
most of the time you are getting a lot
more oil than the water so then halfway
down through the bottle you've used up
all of the oil and you just have tons
of water left and it's pretty annoying
so one exciting thing about this is that it
actually shakes up I timed this once and it
took about 10 minutes for it to completely
separate so that's why I've got a second
bottle here so that I can show you the
two phases as well as the shaken up one
I thought it was just some sort of
accident that this happened but it
turns out it is actually intentional
and bioderma have a patient for
this it's called ecobiological cosmetic
composition with delayed phase separation
so the way this works is they use just
the right amount of polyglyceryl-10
laurate which is a surfactant and that
keeps the two layers mixed together or
emulsified for longer than you need to
get the product out onto your cotton
pad but it still separates into two
layers by the next time you use it
it isn't the biggest issue it's more like mildly
infuriating and I guess it is a bit of a waste if
you have a whole bunch of water left and no oil
in a product but I just thought it was really
neat that someone at bioderma was also mildly
infuriated enough to actually solve this issue
the next product is the naked sundays
spf 50 lip oils this one is less of
like a specific product Innovation as far as
I can tell anyway maybe there is something in
here that I'm missing but the reason it is
innovative I guess is because this product
sort of just ticks off a whole bunch of
things I needed in an SPF lip product
I feel like the main thing that made a difference
for me is actually just the fact
it's in a doe foot applicator
I know I have kind of mixed feelings on
this because it is kind of gross like
you are putting it on your lips and then like
dunking it back in and it goes back and forth
a whole bunch but it is preserved so it should be
fine it's just like mentally a bit gross I guess
but anyway all of that is not an issue
because it just makes it so much easier
to reapply it's so much less messy it's
really easy to just get it on your lips
you don't end up with sticky fingers and that
sticky finger issue is such a big issue when
I'm at the beach I just don't want sand all
over my stuff I want to be able to get the
lip gloss onto my lips without touching
it with my fingers without risking sand
it also just acts like a regular lip gloss it
smells really good they've got four different
flavors I think I've tried watermelon cherry
um coconut those are all really nice their
salted caramel which I'm a bit more iffy on it
sort of has this like coffee ish caramel aroma
I'm sure a lot of people like it to
me it's just weird because it just
makes me feel like I have coffee breath
without the advantage of having coffee
it also has no menthol which is nice
I'm not like a menthol hater I just
don't like the feeling of it for myself on my lips
it also looks really nice on your lips
it's really nice and shiny and it is
really hydrating I have big lips and
all my life they've been really prone
to getting dehydrated and cracked so I am
really picky with lip balms only a few of
them will work for me so looking for an
SPF lip balm it's just been a mission
I guess the main downside is that it does
have a bit of a sunscreen taste but that is
kind of unavoidable with an SPF lip product I
do find that having a doe foot makes it a lot
easier to aim it away from like your lips
so I've had less of an issue with these
on the topic of lips I also wanted
to shout out some normal lip balms
non SPF that I've just found really good this year
the dermal therapy lip balm is really inexpensive
it's about $6 at Chemist Warehouse but it is kind
of hard to get overseas Chemist Warehouse do ship
overseas though if you want to give this a go
I've also been really enjoying the propolis
lip sleeping mask from cosrx this is just a
really nice product it just works really
well for softening my lips overnight
there's also the Australis lip
glaze which has just been my main
lip gloss that I've been using when
I'm not using the Naked Sundays ones
on to some shampoos I have a
super irritation prone scalp
I've had issues all my life and most
shampoos will make my head itchy within
24 hours and that's one of the main
reasons why I wash my hair every day
there are even even some shampoos that make my
head itchy after only 12 hours it is so annoying
so it's really rare that I find shampoos that
keep my scalp calm for more than maybe a day
I will talk about irritated scalp more in
like a later video the science behind why
it happens and what you can do about
it but in the meantime I just wanted
to shout out some shampoos that
worked really well for my scalp
if you have any shampoos that work
really well for your irritated scalp
please let me know in the comments
so I can add them to my testing list
it's always been really annoying to talk
about shampoos because the way they work
is really complicated it's the ingredients
working together I talked about it a bit in
my shampoo science video it is more about the
overall formula and so the ratio of different
ingredients makes a huge difference and you
can't just tell that from an ingredients list
I've tried maybe 50 new shampoos as part
of this quest to work out the holy grail
irritated scalp shampoos the only real patterns
I found are these maybe these will help you
firstly avoiding MI and MCI and these are
really common preservatives I'll put their
full names here a lot of people are allergic to
them they are some of the most common allergens
in beauty products and it's annoying
because they are in a lot of shampoos
the other big thing that helped me is using
shampoos with ingredients that control yeast
you might have heard of malassezia yeast this is
the thing that overgrows and causes dandruff but
this yeast can also cause irritation even
without getting full-on dandruff flakes
one relatively new ingredient that
I've been appreciating is piroctone
olamine this has come in because it's
replacing zinc pyrithione which was
the old super popular anti-dandruff
ingredient that got limited in the EU
this isn't quite as powerful but it is
really nice in formulas because it's
just really bland like you can't tell
that it is an anti-dandruff shampoo
some of my favorite shampoos for this are
listed here but I've also tried shampoos
with it that just do the same irritation thing
so it's clearly not like a complete blanket rule
I've also been using the dercos selenium
sulfide shampoos about once a week but
I'm quite sensitive to the smell of sulfur
because I was working in a lab with lots
of sulfur stuff and this just brings back
terrible memories so I don't love using it
but this is one of the least sulfur
smelling selenium sulfide shampoos
I've used and the effect does last longer so I
don't exactly have to use it every single wash
on top of that I have also found some
shampoos that don't have specific
actives but they've been really nice
for my scalp so I think it is more of
that formulation thing and these
have let me skip days of washing
I'll go into more detail about all
the shampoos I've tried in my later
video whenever that gets done
but this is just a really short
list of some shampoos that let me go
more than 24 hours without washing
maybe it will benefit some of you in the
meantime everything is linked in the description
if you want more reviews you can
check out my reviews playlist if
you want more nerdy beauty science I
did a deep dive into retinol recently
honestly my entire channel is
nerdy beauty science so check
that out and if you haven't like and subscribe